- [Voiceover] Hello
Grammarians, hello Paige.
- [Paige] Hi David.
- [David] We're talking about possession
for names or words ending in the letter S.
There's some confusion, I think,
about what to do if you've got to make
someone's name possessive
if their name ends in an S,
for example, my friend Jess.
If we're talking about Jess,
and we're talking about
something that belongs to her,
like Jess's hat.
We know that there should
be an apostrophe in there,
but should there also be an S?
The answer is, yes.
There had been some debate
over this for some time,
but now, let me tell you, the
answer is yes, Jess's hat.
- [Paige] Right, it seems
like a lot of Esses in a row,
but it's important for understanding
what someone's trying to say.
- [David] Mm-hm, the same
thing happens regardless,
it can be for words ending in S,
like bus.
So if we said, "The air
conditioning on this bus is broken,"
We could say instead to make
it a little bit shorter,
"The bus's air conditioning is broken."
Again, we're just taking all
of that information about
the air conditioning
that belongs to the bus,
all of that is just sort of
being bundled up into this
apostrophe S.
It doesn't matter that bus
already ends with an S,
this works the same as any other word,
we're just gonna say, "bus's."
If we wanted to talk
about the chili culture
of the state of Texas, for example,
we would say, "Texas's chili culture."
- [Paige] Yeah, so it's
exactly the same as any other
singular word even though it ends in S,
you still need another S.
- [David] So just add an apostrophe S,
and if you didn't know, now you know.
That's how you form the possessive for
names or words ending in S.
You can learn anything, David out,
- [Paige] Paige out.